We have a sweep of a previous high, a
candle to closure. The next thing we're
going to do is drop down to our aligned
time frame. How do we confirm this on a
lower time frame or get a validation of
this candle to closure? We look for a
change in the state of delivery. Mark
that out, and then now we can anticipate
price to do what? To continue lower as
long as it remains in respect to the
previous candle's range. I want to see
price respect this area here. So, as we
let this play out, you can see we do go
take out a point of interest, and what
do we notice now? It's a fractal
concept. We have a candle to closure at
a point of interest on the hourly chart.
Not only can this provide a bias for
this next candle to trade lower on a
lower time frame, but we can anticipate
this to be where the high of day forms,
and then what can we look for?
Continuations out of this. We reach up
into a point of interest, and we have
what? A candle to closure. If we are
going to continue and leave this high,
we should anticipate a continuation here
to trade lower.